قبل ايام اعلنت روسيا السيطره على بخمه
المدينه التي دار فيها القتال لاشهر مع
القوات الاوكرانيه انتهاك معارك باخموت
انتهائها ربما سيعني انتقال المعارك
لمناطق اكبر مثل كراماتورسك في مقاطعه الا
ان خبراء يرون ان تسلم الجيش الروسي لزمام
الامور في باخموت سيدفع موسكو للتحول من
مرحله الهجوم كما كان الوضع في المدينه
الى وضعيه الدفاع استعدادا للهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد موسكو طبعا تعمل ايضا
على تمكين خطوط دفاعها وفي ذات الوقت
محاوله ضرب التحركات
الاوكرانيه بالصواريخ والمدفعيه وايضا
سلاح الجو خاصه وان وزاره الدفاع قالت
انها على علم بتفاصيل الخطه الاوكرانيه
المضاده في الاثناء ستعمل روسيا على ضمان
الاحتفاظ بالاراضي التي سيطرت عليها نذكر
هنا اعلان يفغيني بريكوجين قوته ستحتاج
لشهرين للراحه لاعداد وتدريب المقاتلين
الجدد رغم اتخاذ مواضع دفاعيه حول بخموت
شنط روسيا هجوما جويا على مدينه نيبرو
بجنوب شرق اوكرانيا فيما افادت وسال
الاعلام بوقوع السلسله من القصف الروسيه
المتواصل وعلى الجانب الاخر اعلنت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه انها تعمل على بناء
خطوط دفاعيه قويه امام تقدم محتمل للقوات
الروسيه الى مدينتي كراماتورسك
يستبعد خبراء عسكريون قيام اي جانب
بتحركات في القريب العاجل نحو مدن جديده
على ان يقتصر الامر على كر وفر بين
الجانبين في اشتباكات سريعه ايضا الدخول
في معارك استنزاف كما حدث في باخموت ربما
يدفع موسكو للتفكير مع تحشيدك للاليات
والصواريخ التي حصلت عليها من الغرب ولكن
من المتوقع ان تكون المرحله القادمه ساخنه
جدا وفق خبراء مع غموض توجهات الجيشين ان
كان الروسي او الاوكراني في القادم من
الايام طبعا مع الاستعدادات الاوكرانيه
للهجوم المضاد الذي طال انتظاره لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات